my name is Max Koplin I am a physics
student and a student ambassador at
Towson University and today I'm gonna be
talking about beyond the black hole
horizon with Mathematica in which we use
Mathematica to model the interiors of
black holes the only places in the
universe that we will never be able to
observe
so black holes are a very hot topic
right now in physics so recent
observations have proved beyond a doubt
that the paradoxical warping of
space-time that Einstein claimed could
never exist are in fact real and in fact
the the Virgo and LIGO telescopes have
just a few weeks ago detected their
fourth merger of these black holes right
as you can see in this animation here
actually just a few days ago they had
detected a 1/5 merger except it wasn't
with black holes with another very
fascinating kind of cosmic object
neutron stars so actually for this feat
of this of these new insights into black
holes and their mechanics the the 2017
Nobel Prize was has just been awarded to
to Kip Thorne Rainer Weiss and Barry
Baelish or barish that's not Game of
Thrones all right so um so actually Kip
Thorne is I'm sure as many of you know
he's a big Mathematica user and if
you've seen his movie interstellar a lot
of the the the prototypes for the black
hole graphics and animations were
actually first done in Mathematica so
let's let's look back at this for a
second so these measurements that not
like owned Virgo have done have revealed
a new horizon of research and
understanding of black holes for example
the existence of previously undetected
massive mass ranges for black holes and
as our technology continues to increase
and our instruments get more powerful
and accurate our ability to see and
detect black holes will become ever more
accurate and we'll be able to see black
holes in ever higher detail I mean just
just seeing over the last couple years I
mean we can see these black holes you
know in in tremendous detail and it's
only it's only increasing however
no matter how much we increase our
technology and regardless of whatever
future advancements we may make we'll
never be able to see inside a black hole
regardless of how good our technology is
so black hole and let me make this a bit
bigger eighty percent is a bits let's
try so black hole interiors are the only
places in nature that we can never
observe by by definition and therefore
the only way to to see into them is
through mathematics and this has already
been done but these existing
visualizations are are oversimplified
and approximated to the point of
actually being misleading so example
here is a common type of visualization
of the black hole interior is it's just
a basic black hole with mass and spend
but without charge mapped out in a Boyar
Lindquist coordinates and the this
highlights certain features such as the
such as the singularity here and the
event horizon in there in the ergo
burger sphere but again this as well as
other visualizations are are almost
misleading because they all use
coordinate dependent quantities so so
let's talk a bit about that so so the
reason that this picture right the
reason that it looks so simple and you
know it's you know this constant
curvature here um it's it's because of
our choice of coordinate systems but as
many of you know coordinate dependent
quantities can be misleading so if you
look at this map of greenland versus the
united states you it's pretty obvious
that greenland is larger than the US you
know and alaska combined i mean easily
given given this projection of the earth
but if we change but if we look at the
earth from another perspective
so if we look at the earth from another
perspective we can see that their size
of almost reverse I mean here it's
easily apparent that the United States
is much larger than Greenland and the
reason for this is because these were
mapped out in coordinate dependent ways
so if we want to be sure of drawing true
conclusions from things we must express
our results in these terms of invariance
which are quantities that that don't
change will value quantities whose
values remain the same regardless of any
kind of transformation you use so our
objective here was we focus on the
curvature of space-time inside the black
hole horizon and mathematical physicists
have proved that that this that this
curvature is characterized so there's 17
different quantities of black hole
curvature that do not depend on that
that don't depend on your coordinate
system for the most general type of
black holes so what me and my team have
done is that we use Mathematica is
unique capabilities because you really
need a symbolic language to do things
like this for for a general case
mathematic is the only thing that really
that that's capable to calculate in plot
all of these invariant for the first
time this is the first time that all
seventeen curvature invariants of black
hole interiors have ever been have ever
been mapped out and the results differ
dramatically from that basic you know
picture that we saw before so before I
get into the cool pictures and what it
looks like I can't I can't show you what
the stuff is without doing a little bit
of math so the most the most fundamental
part of general relativity is the
relationship that gravity is the shape
of space-time in the shape of space-time
is gravity
and mathematically these are described
by the the metric and so so in a sense
of the metric gravity and the shape of
space and they're kind of they're all
very closely intertwined and the metric
in a sense is a generalization of
Pythagoras theorem which says that the
distance between I mean into D the
distance between two points squared is
just the you know would be x squared
plus y squared while in this case it's
you know XYZ and time well minus CT
squared but anyways so for for some
examples of the metric for flat space
time when there's no gravity right since
gravity is the shape of space-time if
there's no gravity there's no curvature
so that's why so that so space time is
flat when there's no gravity and then a
bit more of an advanced example of a
metric although it's still pretty simple
is the Schwarzschild metric which
describes the space-time around a black
hole that has a mass but no charge or
spin associated with it and the
quantities that we're interested in are
constructed by taking the metric and
combining it in different ways with its
first and second derivatives with
respect to space and time and I mean as
you can see here these these things get
increasingly more complex and as you
take more derivatives with respect to
space and time the number of terms just
goes up incredibly fast so while we were
trying to do this we came in to two main
challenges our two main challenges was
first trying to figure how to translate
the language of general relativity and
Einsteins and Einstein notation into
Mathematica syntax actually well here at
the conference I've already learned much
better ways of doing this we we almost
had to come up with this from scratch so
that was
yeah they're definitely more often ways
to do it than in here but our second
challenge was once we once we translate
this language and we try to compute the
invariance we we get literally dozens of
pages of output and it's hey you can't
do anything with it it's impossible to
understand mathematic has built-in
simplify and trig and trig reductions uh
really really doesn't do much so these
these were two main problems so first to
translate the language of ER into
Mathematica we started looking at some
some resources and a basic version of
this we found in we found in a textbook
and we took that and we extended it and
we we made it much more robust so what
we have here is we have the the metric
for a for a general black hole inside of
it so maybe we could look at this
traditional view to make this look a
make a bit more sense now what we have
to do is that we have to convert we have
to compute the inverse metric the
Christoffel symbols the Riemann tensor
and the the Ricci tensor and scaler so
with this code we were able to to do
that so if we just let's undo that so if
we if we run this let's also get so here
when we compute this here it will just
run this to get all of these all of
these basic parameters of gr and the
important thing is that up not only do
we need to find out the Riemann tensor
but we also need to find the fully
covariant form of it because the
covariant form is useful because it's
scales as you scale your coordinate
system which makes the determining of of
the of the properties that our
coordinate invariant very easy so we do
this with the Ricci
ten sir and so for example let's see
what this Ricci tensor looks like when
we just plugged plug this up again
there's much better ways to do this but
so if we actually decide to look at this
we get let's I mean we get nonsan I mean
this is there's no way to figure out
what this means and is you can see in
here we have you know we have signs and
sine of two theta squared times cosine
of these random things it's I mean it's
this makes no sense and we we can't we
can't do anything with it even
Mathematica is simplify it and trigger
just don't don't really make a dent in
here a similar thing for the Ricci
scalar which by the way is also the
simplest of the 17 curvature invariants
because once we once we find these
tensors we will combine them together to
to get these invariants and the actually
the Ricci scalar is the simplest of
these and the simplest of the invariants
still you can't you can't really do much
with it so so here we came upon our
biggest challenge which was actually
harder than translating this into
Mathematica was simplification now what
we did is that we is that we wanted to
convert all of the trig functions in our
in our tensors into just functions of
one trig function so to do this we made
a trig converter which so we found since
they we couldn't figure out any way to
do this built into Mathematica of course
we googled it and we saw a a similar
thing to this didn't it didn't quite do
what we wanted to do so we we got it we
took it apart and we and we improved on
the code to to create much better
simplification so just just to get to
the good stuff without going through how
all this works so
so for example if we want to convert
something basic like now cosine of two
theta to let's say cosine of theta or if
we wanted to take selling something a
bit a bit more complicated of that like
I don't know a sine of theta squared
minus cosine actually is this keyboard
is word cosine of 3 theta all right and
we want to change that into cosine of
theta then it can do that just like this
now we can't do this for everything
because for some some functions of
course are by value depending on where
you are in your which quadrant here and
so if we just try to to blindly apply to
try to convert let's say sine of theta -
cosine of theta will get we'll get this
by valued function now let's actually
see how well this works with our code so
if you remember for this this reads you
think it was pages long we you know
there's no way to make any sense out of
it well if we actually for that so if we
convert all that whole long thing into
just terms of cosine theta then
hopefully this doesn't take too long
then we'll be able to greatly greatly
simplify it so let's see it remember
that thing you know I just scroll
forever I didn't even get to the end of
it it was very long well now it's just
this so immense simplification and
remember that the scalar thing that was
that was also extremely long well when
we convert everything in this into
cosine of theta we get zero so that that
was really great so the first the first
invariant that we found is actually zero
and we were great to find this but it's
actually a known result that this is
zero so that was great for confirming
what we did because
couldn't we couldn't confirm all of the
invariants because a lot of the
invariants haven't been found yet now to
compute the first violin variant
let's see I'll run through this because
I know you guys want to see the pretty
pictures so let's see I don't think I
actually have to run any of this so well
here is the here is the the first violin
variant here and as you can see again
very pretty incomprehensible cosine of
two theta
like where's all this cosine 2 theta to
the 8 pretty funky but when we wouldn't
we run convert to it to make everything
in terms of cosine theta it's greatly
simplified now we have to do some
massaging with us so we just have to do
some it's a manual manual
simplifications but here we have found
the very first invariant the very first
curvature invariant well actually I
guess the second one well the the very
first nonzero curvature invariant for
black holes and this will allow us to
have a much a much more accurate view of
the interior black holes then than
anything else and this is actually what
it looks like and this is just showing
the this is showing the the magnitude of
the of the curvature and you know
there's there's some interesting things
here for example in that in that earlier
thing with the borderland Chris you saw
you know they're these spheres but they
all had this positive curvature to it
and here you can you can see that in
many places the curvature is negative so
that that's an interesting result so
this is actually a first look into the
interior of rotating spinning and
charged black holes oh well I guess you
can't have a mathematical presentation
without something going wrong so okay so
well so let's skip through the second
violin bearing two so oh okay so this
this is this is just so for the second
violin variant we need to use the levy
chibita
tensor and it's really complicated
because it's you know it's not just a
basic 2d tensor so that I think the best
way to visualize it is to kind of take
cross sections of it but anyways
skipping through the results this is
what we got for the second violin
variant and when we plot both of these
together let me make this bigger oh we
get this and this this is showing the
relationship between these two different
measures of curvature and we can
actually something interesting is to
show how this how this curvature changes
as you change the angular momentum of
the black hole because we can see some
pretty significant changes so if we were
to actually I don't around this you know
because it's already here
and it takes forever so here you can
actually see that as the curvature as
you increase your angular momentum the
the curvature stretches out which and it
it gets it gets flattened almost almost
like a normal spinning object would
expect so and again there's some very
important what all right
so the important thing is that these
negative regions of curvature have some
have some pretty important implications
though actually in the in the literature
that we were looking at it was actually
it was actually pretty controversial
whether as you weatherize R approaches
zero if you would get whether the
whether the curvature becomes negative
and a lot of things said that you know
the curvature will stay positive always
even as you even as you approach the the
singularity but here we've shown that
the curvature is actually that the that
the curvature does become negative as
you approach the as R gets small we're
worried now that I I think the most
beautiful way to express this is an
aspherical coordinates because when we
take the first violent variant and we we
put it into spherical polar coordinates
we get this this is the this is the the
best analog the best accurate analog to
that to that basic boyer Lindquist you
know system so that's so so that that
simple diagram from before that I just
assumed pass that that's very inaccurate
well it's well I would say it's
misleading depending on what you're
trying to look at but this is actually
the most this is the most accurate
representation of the interiors of black
holes that we have let me make this a
bit bigger let's hope it doesn't crash
again so yeah here you go and you can
just you can see it's very strange
because yeah it's positive in a lot of
parts and then it's negative and it
intersects with itself and and it's what
what we've seen from this is that the
interiors of black holes are much more
complex and beautiful than we then we
had ever previously imagined so just to
show this again with changing angular
momentum
you can you can see again how this
flattens out but I wish I could zoom in
a bit more but actually well actually
this is a listen and so I don't think I
can change all of them but anyways yeah
I don't think I can no because what I
did is that I just since it's very
computationally heavy I just I made a
bunch of I just made a bunch of
different value so I can't rotate all of
them can rotate this one now this one
looks nice so I I think I think this
this picture is this is this is the main
picture this is the main thing you
should take out of it of in in a sense
what the interior what the curvature
inside of a black hole looks like that
will never be able to observe directly
because we can't because of properties
of the black hole what it is an image of
the of the curvature of the of the
magnitude of the curvature a different
radii from the a different radii from
the center of the black hole so actually
the larger value as it goes out this is
actually are getting smaller so you can
see that the curvature is very large as
you approach the as you approach the
singularity and then and then the
curvature gets smaller the farther out
you go but the farther you but as you
but as you go through different regions
of the black hole the curvature does a
lot of different things yes yeah yes
this is the viol invariant and just just
some other interesting things from this
is are these regions of negative
curvature and I I actually personally
don't know a lot about this but the
people in my in my research group they
actually just heard some very
interesting relationships that that come
from this negative curvature for example
so some implications is that the the
Jets that you can see coming from from
some active galactic nuclei are related
to this negative curvature that that
results from deep inside the event
horizon of the black hole from inside
the event horizon this negative
curvature can result in
jets and also these these really really
beautiful firming bubbles this is also
thought to thought to emanate or it's
thought to be related to the it's not to
be related to the to this negative
curvature and uh so just just some
conclusions so the curvature inside
actual black holes not you know not not
these approximations can have both
negative and positive values certainly
not constant and very complex and the
interiors are much more complex and
beautiful than we ever imagined and
let's see what else is yeah just just
that the biggest thing about what we
discovered is that we don't actually
know exactly what all the implications
of this are so well with these applets
so but the first step into discovering
what these mean is to find them and
that's what we've done here for all 17
curvature invariants oh thank you oh
yeah
I'm well we haven't done that and what
what we calculate here yet we're first
stable black holes that didn't just go
through a merger but I I couldn't see a
reason that we couldn't I mean if we can
if we can map out the mathematically the
interiors of two black holes we can
simulate of course what what their
interiors would look like and I I can
only imagine what that what that must
look like yes similar answer yeah it's
no
mmm okay that's it so the flu yeah yeah
okay yes yeah all right all right so
yeah thank you
I got a got to get out of here now I'm
holding everybody else up
[Applause]